some of you watching this might not have
seen the force awakens yet firstly why
did you click on this video you should
be avoiding spoilers secondly go and see
the force awakens and thirdly yes there
will be spoilers in this video you have
been warned I'm you see James and this
is your spoiler if it gamespot news
update the force awakens has its dark
bits you know that bit with the thing
and the other bit with that other thing
we obviously can't get footage yet but
the next film helmed by looper director
ian johnson is apparently even darker
john boyega who played Finn in the force
awakens recently talked to Vogue about
being able to openly talk about spoilers
from the movie and teased some
information about the next film he says
it feels good but now we're just
starting work on Star Wars 8 the next
film so I'm back to keeping secrets
again it's great much darker but we're
very excited it's likely that the next
film will deal with what kylo Ren his
knights the first order and supreme
leader Snoke er up to and we'll probably
see mad chap general Hux as he slowly
descends into complete insanity boyega
was also asked around how extensive his
preparation for the lightsaber scenes
were he said for this film we really
just took it scene by scene there wasn't
a huge regime my part in the next film
will be much more physical so I might be
in the gym a bit more well I'm still
running on my new year's resolution so
me to John me too what did you think of
the force awakens do you think Star Wars
can keep this hot streak going even if
JJ is not directing the next episode let
me know in the comments below or come
find me on Twitter I'm at Lucy James
games remember to keep it gamespot com
for all the latest Star Wars knees and
thanks for watching